ان شاء الله
حبيبي
[موسيقى]
اخبار الجزيره اهلا بكم جنين تشيع جثمان
الشابين الفلسطينيين فؤاد عابد ومحمد
حوشيه اللذين استشهد خلال الاقتحام
الاسرائيلي للمدينه في الضفه الغربيه
الفصائل الفلسطينيه تدين الاقتحام
والخارجيات الفلسطينيات تقول انها ستتابع
جرائم الاحتلال في المحاكم الدوليه في حين
هدمت قوته الاحتلال منزلي عائلتين منافذ
عمليه حاجز الجلمه في سبتمبر الماضي
رئيسه حكومه الوحده في ليبيا يتهم راي
السيد مجلس الاعلى للدوله ومجلس النواب
بعقد صفقات وصفها بالمشوهه وذلك لتقاسم
السلطه وتعطيل الانتخابات والمجلس الاعلى
للدولي يقرر دفع تعليق التواصل مع مجلس
النواب والعمل على انجاز قاعده دستوريه
تؤدي الى انتخابات العامه
بعد عوده الهدوء الى الحدود بين صربيا
وكوسوفو روسيا تتهم سلطات الكوسوفو
بالتوجه نحو التصعيد بدعم امريكيا اوروبي
ورئيسه وزراء كوسوفي يطالب الناس بتعزيز
وجوده العسكري بعد التوترات مع بيت جراده
يذكر ان روسيا وصربيا لا تعترفان باستقلال
مكتب الامم المتحده لتنسيق الشؤون
الانسانيه في السودان يعلن تسجيل اكثر من
مليون و700 الف اصابه بمرض الملاريا خلال
الاشهر الماضيه مشيرا الى ان اعداد
الاصابه بالملاريا تجاوزت عتبه الوباء في
اثنتي عشره ولايه وحضر من ضعف القطاع
الصحي في مواجهه الملاريا الى اللقاء